[Applaudissements]
bonjour tout le monde
je sais pas pour vous mais un jour de la
terre
annick cherche ou que je subis une tonne
des mises à jour sur l'association
environnementale et sur comment protéger
notre belle planète
cette année je tombais sur l'initiative
de jobs qui présente cinq engagements et
actions individuelles pour qu'on puisse
atteindre l'accord de paris sur les
changements climatiques
le premier engagement ben c'est
d'acheter moins de trois vêtements neufs
par amy
pour tout à fait
le deuxième c'est de conserver nous
apparaît électronique plus de sept ans
avant le terme ans et le leur je pense
que je récolte les troisièmes c'est
d'avoir une alimentation à base de
végétaux et sans gaspillage je peux tout
à faire conclut le quatrième c'est de
faire un vol d'avion de plus de trois
heures à tous les huit ans
non
et le dernier mais c'est de ne pas avoir
de tout garder la sienne très longtemps
donc mon vélo jeu lips garde longtemps
donc est yes mais malgré tout à un usage
je me suis rendu compte à quel point que
je tiens loin du compte et qui en
général dans notre société on est loin
du compte seulement avec les actions
individuelles
si on regarde au niveau des
gouvernements et au niveau des grandes
entreprises mais en se fiant à leur à
leurs engagements
on s'enligne vrai que d'avoir un
réchauffement 2.7 degrés d'ici la fin du
siècle il s'appelle ninive a dit que 10
des conséquences catastrophiques
surtout si on considère que nos
objectifs il un point de limiter la
hausse à 1.5 des grilles et reste
beaucoup de travail à faire
au niveau de l'activisme
environnementale payer des gains
importants qui ont été réalisés dans les
dernières années l'enjeu c'est que les
résultats dépend de ce que d'autres
veulent bien faire donc des résultats
concrets à court terme sont limitées
avec soeur ne peuvent rien convient de
parler d'éco anxiété
j'insiste le cercle rouge pour présenter
une idée je crois fermement qu'une des
actions qui ont des formes d'action qui
a le plus de chance depuis la 35e régis
et l'entrepreneuriat 1 pat
l'entrepreneuriat prête une forme
d'activisme
entrepreneuriat lui permet de
revendiquer des nouvelles façons de
faire mais aussi lit mettre en action
le c'est mon premier tube ans
donc qu'est ce que j'attends par
l'entrepreneuriat impact mais tout
d'abord votre peau noire et un pacte
vise à répondre à des vrais besoins de
la société
et ensuite le permet le modèle
d'affaires est centré sur une action qui
est social et environnemental donc
chaque dollar de revenu permet d'appuyer
la réalisation de la mission si on prend
l'exemple d'une ferme maraîchère
biologique
les permis de produire des légumes pour
nourrir les gens et en même temps mais
de ramener la production localement tout
en éliminant l'utilisation de pesticides
si on prend l'exemple d'une friperie
nous a permis de venir les gens ce
système portant et ça permet de limiter
la production de nouveaux vêtements dont
on connaît l'empreinte écologique qui
est important
six des leurs en font souvent
l'apparence bien simple même banal mais
dans le fond des choses et vient de
renverser le statu quo
et qu'est ce qu'ont en commun les
entreprenants les activistes et c'est
l'instinct dosée et d'agir même si on
leur dit que c'est impossible c'est
exactement ce trait de caractère là
qu'on a besoin maintenant
c'est ce que j'ai eu la chance
d'expérimenter à la fin de mes études
sienne vers citya brute en fait au début
j'avais même pas que je démarrais
l'entreprise au début les amis vous en
avez un but en tête c'était de
démocratiser les moyens de fabrication
pour permettre à chaque citoyen d'être
un créateur qui on le fait en démarrant
la fabrique une coopérative d'intérêt
collectif qui permettait travailler le
bois le métal l'électronique les métiers
d'art en est le coût de plus de dix
mille pieds carrés ou centre-ville de
sherbrooke et au delà des espoirs au
delà des machines on est surtout via la
russie moblin communauté autour des
trois axes clés de notre mission
vraiment bien on a réussi à rejoindre
plus de 800 membres pour les initiés à
la fabrication
leur permettre de fabriquer lui-même
l'objet
ensuite on ait pu soutenir une trentaine
d'artistes d'artisans pour qu'ils
deviennent eux mêmes entrepreneurs et
puissent vivre de leur création
ici à sherbrooke
troisièmement on est plus ouvrir d
argent à plusieurs centaines de
personnes de manière à ce qu'ils
centaines de personnes éloignées du
marché du travail par des formations
adaptées de manière à ce qu'ils puissent
découvrir de nouveaux métiers
donc pour moi la fabrique c'est surtout
une action directe par les ags jectif
sociaux et environnementaux
tout en permettant à des gens dans
vivent grâce aux revenus que l'on compte
générer
et grâce à cette expérience là mais j'ai
surtout vu la force d'une communauté qui
étaient mobilisés autour d'une mission
hills à me démontrer tout notre
potentiel d'apporter les changements
qu'on souhaite voir
par chance à l'université de sherbrooke
mais il ya de nombreux projets
d'entreprenariat et pas qui émerge à
chaque année que ce soit au niveau
technologique ou nouveau des biens et
services au niveau de la santé qu'une
vous de l'innovation sociale par exemple
avec les commotions convient de voir
donc les exemples sont nombreux surtout
les personnes étudiants temps tout le
potentiel dernier une nouvelle se dit
qu'on a besoin de voir et sous tous deux
mettant en place des solutions radicales
dans chacune des phases la société
corpus réussir la transition écologique
et dans les instants d'enseignement on a
la chance d'avoir toutes les ressources
tout le personnel pour appuyer ce projet
là de manière rationnelle du succès
je prends l'exemple de desertec ce fonds
un robot désherbeur où les champs de
légumes racines de manière à réduire le
personnel nécessaire et surtout données
d'utilisation de pesticides
et ceux qui pleurent peut être formés à
travers des cours du bac oui ont pu
identifier le problème générer des idées
et faire une première version de la
solution
ensuite grâce à l'appui de l'écosystème
entrepreneurial de l'université de la
ville meilleure une reconnaissance au
niveau local au niveau national et même
au niveau international ce qui est mis
en confiance pour démarrer une
entreprise est allé plus loin que le
projet
enfin le milieu de la recherche a aussi
contribué à permettant à ce mot michaud
a dit fondateur de l'entreprise des
phares sa maîtrise sur son projet pour
développer la science autour de ce est
de rendre la technologie plus mature
pour atteindre le marché ils sont
justement dans les champs en train de
faire leurs premiers tests cet été où
l'entrepreneuriat ce devrait être un 1
une profession qui soit elle qui soit
mis de l'avant par les actions
d'enseignement de la même façon qu'on
encourage des gens de venir des employés
d'autres entreprises ici les cours en
entrepreneuriat mais ne peut être
directement voir la création d'une
nouvelle entreprise mais toutes les
compétences développées sont transférés
en vol les milieux de travail et
permettent à ces gens de devenir des
acteurs de changement dans leur milieu
est ce on a définitivement besoin
maintenant
a multiplié les petites entreprises que
ça plus réellement faire un changement
dans à mon avis qu'on a le besoin
présentement ces dissolutions à moyenne
échelle laisse moi même expliqué il
s'agit en petite échelle entre les les
actions plus individuelles ont besoin
d'une masse critique support important
et on n'a ni peur tout à fait là
malheureusement nouveau diddy
gouvernance des grandes entreprises et
une grande inertie à protéger leurs
actifs actuels donc on n'a pas le temps
d'attendre un prêt ce dont je connais le
besoin ces solutions un échelle humaine
y où on peut expérimenter tester de
nouvelles solutions de faire les choses
de vivre de manière plus durable
donc le défi après ceux ci de mettre à
l'échelle six projets leur est d'avoir
des plaques qui rend les trois façons
que je le vois d'abord bien évidemment
le gouvernement y lit grand institutions
peuvent être un appui dans l'adoption de
ces nouvelles solutions là on l'a vu en
trop avec les centres de la petite
enfance les six pays qui sont un grand
exemple d'innovation sociale au québec
en france est souvent plus mais c'était
un réseau de garderies coopérative qui
ont émergé dans les années 90 qui était
en quelque sorte nationalisé par le
gouvernement y multiplier partout au
québec
la deuxième manière
si de développer des technologies de les
vendre à licence à des plus grandes
entreprises pour accélérer changement
c'est le cas entre des skis ferréol qui
sont conçus fabriqués au québec mais
sont en train de développer un ski qui
va être recyclables de manière a
grandement réduit l'empreinte écologique
ils sont empreints de travail des grands
joueurs de l'industrie du ski pour
qu'ils puissent adopter si ces
technologies là et augmenter encore plus
leur impact sur l'environnement mais
diminuer leur impact voyez sculpteur
et en fin de compte veiller le marché
qui peut permettre une adoption
exponentielle de nouveaux produits on
peut prendre l'exemple ici des
applications de transport mobile des
applications mobiles de transport et
comme l'application hubert et bien à new
york en seulement trois ans les
applications comme hubert ont dépassé
l'industrie sans nom du taxi
par contre si on laisse le marché par
les choses l'enjeu c'est que souvent les
travailleurs peuvent payer le prix de ce
c'est ce qui est arrivé ici
ces dernières un des enjeux
l'entrepreneuriat c'est que
l'entrepreneuriat doit s'inscrire dans
l'économie actuelle qui est souvent
pointée du doigt comme un des grands
responsables de la crise climatique
aujourd'hui mais pour remédier à ça il
ya deux éléments importants pour moi
tout d'abord on doit s'assurer que les
moyens financiers pour appuyer les
entreprises à un pacte sont axées sur le
long terme et inclut des facteurs de
réussite qui sont sociaux et
environnementaux aussi et ensuite c'est
important de miser sur la création des
pme et d'entreprises d'économie sociale
pour vraiment créer des emplois qui sont
durables plutôt que de miser sur des
licornes donc des entreprises à forte
croissance dans le but principal de
rentabiliser et maximiser les retours
financiers là dessus
puis parlant d'argent justement bain
malheureusement la fabrique dû fermer
ses portes en 2020 par manque de fonds
c'était quand même vendu s'il pour moi
mais surtout pour tous les membres qui
l'hiver la création quotidiennement dans
les ateliers
trouver un modèle d'affaires viable en
entrepreneuriat puis en particulier on
entrevoit n'a rien et pas que c'est un
défi de tous les jours et des moments
j'aurais mis à être plus business
qu'activité
le mari tout ce que je retiens de l'
aventure c'est que l'entrepreneuriat
c'est plus que de démarrer une
entreprise cette porte une idée cette
porte une vision il malgré la fermeture
des ateliers bain la mission de faire de
chaque citoyen un créateur continue
après sa fermeture et plusieurs membres
qui ont développé et démarrer différents
ateliers ici à sherbrooke pour continuer
leurs créations mais aussi continuer à
mobiliser les citoyens vers la création
aussi il ya différents membres de
l'équipe qui ont pu participer au
développement de projets d'encore plus
grande envergure que ce soit ici à
l'université ou dans le milieu culturel
ici à sherbrooke
donc en entrepreneuriat démarrer une
entreprise
c'est principalement c'est pas une fin
en soi mais c'est principalement un
moyen pour faire progresser la société
et pour transformer l'économie
et pour compléter je peux faire le jeu
de la main tout seul fait que j'ai
invité tout le monde a levé le poing
dans les airs que maire du broc
activistes ouest une belle image la
salle je passerai pas de manif l'enquêté
vous peut donc ce qu'est ce que j'invite
des farces et de
lever les doigts tranquillement et de
pensée soit maintenant autant tout à
cinq entreprises en démarrage petites
entreprises que vous pouvez appuyer soit
individuellement soit dans votre travail
et peut-être y ajouter les projets qui
vous trotte dans la tête pour devenir à
votre tour des entrepreneurs activistes
merci tout le monde va soirée
[Applaudissements]